bois d'amont petit village du jura situé
à 1km sein de la frontière suisse non
loin de murray fait actuellement parler
de lui pourquoi me direz-vous
eh bien on y fabrique des quantités de
boîtes de fromage les trente artisans
enfants environ 600 milles par jour et
ces emballages d'épicéa ou de sapin ne
contiendront pas uniquement des fromages
en effet les jeunes filles de bois
d'amont y glisse des messages en vue de
trouver des correspondants ou peut-être
qui sait des maris la première à avoir
eu l'idée d'une correspondance par les
boîtes de fromage c'est régine harb et
dites-moi origines je vous interromps
dans votre travail
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé exactement
alors c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous
avez écrit dans les boîtes à fromage si
j'écris mon jeune harvey saison voilà ma
demande correspondant à s'esquisser
bush cherchait uniquement à trouver des
correspondants ou des maris des fleurs
uniquement des correspondants des causes
pendantes département sont les jeunes
gens ne voient d'abord sont bien très
bien
yapo partie et bien si vous allez à
l'épousé alors j'espère que monsieur par
exemple à quel âge 18 ans ça vous gêne
se débrouille aussi remet complètement
égal aucune raison obscure n'irons
chercher ailleurs s'ils ne veulent pas
sur le passé ou bien honorer les
travailleurs
vous êtes beau garçon portant robe salée
pour les ego elles vous plaisent les
filles du pays
voyez là certaines bon vous savez tant
qu'à moi bon célibataire aucune
importance vous avez cherché où les
filles maintenant
aulas n'a toujours on les aime bien
quand même
mais il y en a trop abondamment on est
trop de jeu une pour nombre de filles à
vous en trouver d'autres
ouais on en trouve de robin pas besoin
d'aller loin juste après la frontière
qui ont un trou
[Musique]